well look you have
obviously a ton of success and you've
done so many things and i always like to
go back
i mean you're from the south side of
chicago
yeah my engineer ryan over here was like
well that's that's the tough part of
chicago
i'm like is it was it it's not the north
it's the south it's always the south
but the south side did you was it a
tough childhood
yeah yeah it was man but you know when
you're in it as a kid you don't look at
it as tough because that's just what
you're used to you know what i mean when
i when i was a kid i mean there was a
lot of gang violence a lot of fights a
lot of gunshots being shot at sometimes
stuff like that but you just looked at
it like
i remember the time being at the park we
played basketball at the park and people
started shooting
now we just ducked down and like ran off
and then like once we get a block away
you and your boys like laughing like
damn that was crazy
as opposed to going
we almost lost our lives like you know
it's just
it toughens you up to to the point where
not a lot of things get to you um
so you get you get used to it it's not a
it's not it's not the best way to get
used to something no because
unfortunately a lot of kids don't
survive that a lot of families are
broken up by gang violence and drugs and
you know policing in some of these
neighborhoods but
it it
it definitely forms you in the way you
think when you when you get a little bit
older but
when we when i was
when i was
15 i want to say we moved to the burbs
like you go from the south side of
chicago which is like
like parts of it was like the hood hood
and you move to like the western burbs
where you're where it is like suburbia
damn near you know what i mean it's like
people leave their doors unlocked and
you know like that you're like man
this is crazy
um and it definitely changes the way you
think you start to see
the differences in the neighborhoods the
differences in your friends their
upbringings
you know what life was like for them
having a father around and you know and
you start to you start to see where
things could have been different for you
but you still appreciate where you come
from because there's a level of
awareness that i have that you know
certain kids didn't have right was your
father around
no no so my father uh
my father was actually deported back in
the day
back to belize
uh because my family's from belize um so
he had deported back because of drugs
you know
so you're selling a lot of drugs this
man melts a little a lot were you
around that were you aware of that at a
young age you knew what was going on
oh yeah oh yeah yeah but again it was
normal
because everybody's daddies did it you
know what i'm saying like and they did
in front in front of the children
yeah you grew up i mean there were
crackheads
walking around sometimes you know we
come home sometimes like
would be missing from the house
you know like
like we had a we had someone who lived
across the street
who used to just walk around butt naked
and walk out like and turn our water
homes on and
put water in a bucket and she was just
like boobs out she didn't care she was
just he was on drugs and this is how she
was gonna live her life and it was very
normal to us and we were like hey she
was like hey y'all
and
she was like
sometimes she would leave the water on
and water bill would be high as
just
flooding our grass